there were more protests overnight in
minnesota over the police shooting of
dante wright in brooklyn center
minnesota
former officer kim potter appeared
remotely in court yesterday for killing
the 20-year-old during a traffic stop
she is charged with
second-degree manslaughter after police
say she accidentally fired her gun
instead of her taser she's due back in
court may 17th
wright's family says they want
accountability but nothing will bring
back their son
even then when that happens if that even
happens
we're still going to bury our son we're
still never going to be able to see
our baby boy that
we're never going to have again dante
wright's funeral will be held thursday
in minneapolis the world has been
focused on minnesota this week amid
calls for justice in two separate cases
involving black men
killed during police encounters in
addition to the dante wright case we're
close to learning the fate of former
minneapolis police officer
derrick chauvin who's on trial accused
of murdering george floyd last may
this morning 60 minutes plus
correspondent wesley lowry reflects
on how the two events are triggering new
layers of trauma
and anxiety for black americans
the eyes of the nation are on minnesota
where protests rage in the streets
following the police shooting of dante
wright
and a minneapolis jury will soon debate
whether to convict former police officer
derek shovin
in last summer's videotaped killing of
george floyd
but among the sea of scenes a particular
moment stands out
as wright's family addressed a crowd of
reporters the slain man's aunt
revealed that there was a direct
connection between wright and floyd
his girlfriend was a teacher for my
nephew
two men whose names will now forever be
connected in death
were one degree of separation from being
acquainted in life
it was a reminder that black america
though diverse and complex
remains relatively small the anxiety
that accompanies each new video of a
black man or woman
killed by the police is not theoretical
but the very literal
fear that the next victim could be
someone you know the families of the
slain become bound together in grief
while the deaths of their sons and
daughters become symbols for the anger
and fear of an entire race of people
mothers
fathers sisters and sons find themselves
thrust into activism
while knowing that only a few people in
the crowd understand their pain
say his name and when the people pour
into the streets
whether chauvin is found guilty or
innocent it's only a matter of time
before another name becomes a hashtag
and another family joins the fraternity
of the grieving
for cbs this morning wesley lowry
wesley lowry's so well said and i think
that's what's so concerning because it
escalates so quickly
that's a problem just doing ordinary
things escalate so quickly seemingly
when you're dealing with someone of
color there's something circulating
online
right now about a 61 year old man in
minnesota
who is holding on to you know a
policeman is holding on to his truck
he's backing up he's hitting police cars
the police officer is holding on he's
taking off
they're standing there with guns drawn
and nothing happens to him nothing's
okay
he is okay he's arrested and he's okay
and these stories that we cover they
feel familiar i think people should
remember that they're not inevitable
we can't change the way the world is we
can change the way this country is
but they're happening over and over they
are they are